well german chancellor angela merkel has
said germany will leave afghanistan with
other coalition forces on the 31st of
august the announcement came as part of
the chancellor's address to the german
parliament as a government seeks
retroactive approval for its military
mission in afghanistan the largest in
bundesvare history opposition parties
have heavily criticized the government's
handling of the withdrawal
and chancellor merkel are called on
western countries to continue their
support for local support staff even
after coalition troops have gone
the end of the airlift which u.s
president joe biden
adhered to he didn't give us an
extension yesterday
means that this will be the end of our
efforts and that will mean
supporting the afghan
staff that are even more desperate now
than they were when the taliban first
took over
and we must protect them
and this means that we are working
intensely in the days remaining us
to find ways
to continue to help those who helped us
to offer protection
not least through civilian operations of
the airport in kabul and it's also about
offering humanitarian support
for those who need this help more than
ever
well let's get more on the chancellor
merkel's speech to the german parliament
with the w chief political editor
michaela kufner who is there at the
bundestag welcome michaela despite
admitting that quotes we were all wrong
about the speed of the taliban victory
end quote the chancellor was in no mood
to apologize
no she wasn't she actually said that the
initial aim had been achieved which was
to prevent any terrorist attack to start
from afghanistan's ground once again
although of course that we're heading
into new territory there all together
with is um already being reported to
arrive at the scene um she said she
would do several things now some 600
million euros have been earmarked to for
humanitarian assess assistance through
u.n agencies but also to support
countries in the region not to hand over
to a taliban government that she made
clear also germany would continue to try
and get as many people out as possible
and yes it wants to talk to the taliban
and get guarantees and to somehow
safeguard people who are still stuck
there but that is a little um to really
um help um calm those fears right now
with the end of this evacuation of
course being imminent
and she directly addressed the
criticisms that the german evacuation
had begun too late
yes she said it's easy to now
say that
what would have been better in the past
she spoke of difficult choices that
needed to be made
she said that one had to decide whether
to weaken the government by already
pulling people out there were great
fears amongst the previous government
one can say now that this would start a
panic but the fact is that germans were
amongst the last to realize how
dangerous the situation was even in
evacuating their own staff and there is
a painstaking search now for where the
key mistake was made but what is clear
is that individual ministries were kind
of pushing responsibility towards each
other and that doesn't seem to measure
up to the magnitude of this collective
failure here
so more questions being raised and if we
weren't just four weeks away from the
general election here in germany
i dare say that angela mackel remaining
in
office would even be in doubt but with
those elections just a few weeks away
the interesting thing here will be what
people's will people will vote for when
they go to the ballot box with
afghanistan german foreign policy now
clearly an election issue
and i wanted to pick up on that point so
germans do see that this crisis in
afghanistan as being relevant to next
month's election
absolutely and there seems to be um
there's
been actually demonstrations in the
streets here uh as well um or not huge
ones but um people do feel a
responsibility towards um those people
who were trying to build a democratic
state in afghanistan and all germans are
watching almost in
real time
how their own government is simply
helpless in a situation the entire g7
nations appear helpless at this very
moment in time and that's a source of
great insecurity so
we have this imminent crisis right now
but this is a political earthquake that
has shaken confidence in this government
right now and that is for sure going to
play out into this election campaign in
the next coming weeks with a lot of um
confidence that needs to be fought back
for
all right thank you for that chief
political editor michaela kufner